der mann den er gerade sehen 5 ist romas
zu nehmen
eine der einflussreichsten imame in den
usa ist eine der vielen muslimischen
führer die in letzter zeit sehr harte
kritik an frankreich
andere wie zb der türkische präsident
erdogan sind sogar noch weiter gegangen
und haben moslems zu einem boykott aller
französischen produkte aufgerufen
wieso aber schon ausgerechnet gegen
frankreich plötzlich so viele islamische
führer den fast ihre glaubensgenossen
nun der hauptgrund ist das was der
französische präsident in dänemark den
kampf gegen den islamischen separatisten
dieser kampf ist bitter nötig geworden
denn mittlerweile scheint klar zu sein
dass frankreich ein gewaltiges problem
mit dem radikalen islam hat dabei hat
makro immer wieder deutlich gemacht dass
das problem nicht die gemäßigten muslime
sind sondern der radikalismus dieser
region
warum also haben so viele islamische
führer die ja von sich behaupten nicht
radikal zu sein
trotzdem das gefühl dass man ihnen die
schuld dafür gibt wieso fühlen sie sich
angegriffen
wieso ziehen sie im kampf gegen
radikalismus nicht mit anderen an einem
stark und was genau sind das für
probleme die frankreich mit den
radikalen islam hat in diesem video
werden euch die antworten auf all diese
fragen und noch viel mehr liefern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am 16 oktober 2020 wurde samuel partie
lehrer an einer französischen
mittelschule von einem 18-jährigen
moslems tschetschenischer herkunft auf
offener straße entpuppt der mörder
abdullah fans of war bereits vor zehn
jahren mit seinen eltern als schutz
suchen dann nach frankreich gekommen
dass ihm und seiner familie asyl für
ihre angeblichen verfolgung in russland
gewährt das motiv des mörders der
geschichtslehrer partie hatte gemäss
lehrplan in seinem unterricht das recht
auf freie meinungsäusserung diskutiert
und als unterrichtsmaterial die boa mit
karikaturen aus der französischen
satirezeitschrift charlie hebdo benutzt
in china hat der vater einer schülerin
die an dem tag gar nicht anwesend war
sah seine religion beleidigt und wollte
den lehrer diese schande nicht
durchgehen lassen ertrag eine massive
hetzkampagne gegen party los und
erstattete strafanzeige wegen des
zeigens von pornografie vor
minderjährigen der lehrer musste sich
deswegen vor der schulleitung und gerade
polizei rechtfertigen und ein
französischer moslem marokkanischer
herkunft namens abdul hakim staff rio i
veröffentlicht über partie ein video in
dem er den hass seiner glaubensgenossen
gegen den lehrer noch mehr anheizt
durch all diesen druck wo die massive
hasskampagne gegen ihn in den sozialen
medien knickte partie ein und erklärte
er werde in zukunft das thema
meinungsfreiheit einander eines anderen
beispiels unterrichten aber auch dieses
zurückweichen vor dem radikalen islam
heißt ihn nicht mehr sein leben zu
retten denn abdullah angst europa
bereits auf ihn aufmerksam geworden und
fuhr zur partie schule
dort angekommen zahlte er ein paar
zufällig anwesenden schülern insgesamt
300 euro damit diese in hessen seien
auch was zu finden und nach mehr als
zwei stunden gelang ihnen das auch als
partie zu fuß nach hause gehen wollte
nur 500 meter von der schule entfernt
start der mörder den lehrer mehrfach in
den bauch dann schnitt er ihn mit einem
35 cm langen messer unter frenetischen
allahu akbar rufen seinen kopf ab und
twitterte ein foto des abgetrennten
haupt zusammen mit der nachricht an
makro herrscher der ungläubigen ich habe
einen seiner höllenhund exekutierte es
gewagt hat mohammed zu erniedrigen nach
seiner tat wurde der mörder von der
polizei erschossen sein leichnam nach
tschetschenien überführt und dort im
rahmen einer feierlichen zeremonie mit
200 gästen nach islamischem ritus
beigesetzt
[Musik]
und um diesmal alles in die richtige
perspektive zu rücken
seit 2005 10 haben islamische
terroristen in frankreich insgesamt 250
menschen ermordet dazu gehören auch die
schöpfer genau jener
mohammed-karikaturen welche partie im
rahmen seines unterrichts und
meinungsfreiheit seien schülern zeigt
offensichtlich hat frankreich also ein
gewaltiges problem mit dem radikalen
islam und nein nicht nur lauter rechte
sind dieser ansicht insgesamt 180
prozent aller franzosen hatten radikale
moslems und den islamischen terrorismus
für eines der schrecklichsten probleme
unter denen irland zum leiden hat
natürlich halten diese menschen nicht
alle muslime suite terroristen aber es
beunruhigt sie ungemein wenn über den
terror hinaus auch noch hohe islamische
führer zu einem boykott gegen frankreich
aufrufen und das nur weil die grand
nation ihre ureigensten und
gesellschaftlichen werte verteidigen
möchte natürlich sind sie auch ein wenig
verstört von der unendlichen komplexität
der islamischen ordnung oder besser
gesagt fast warnung der amerikanische
immer zum beispiel den wir am anfang des
videos gesehen haben ruft auf der einen
seite zum boykott frankreichs aus erhält
auf der anderen aber regelmäßig
morddrohungen von anderen moslem gruppen
wie zum beispiel da ist ja die bunte
welt des islam kann schon ganz schön
verwirrt sein nicht nur für die
ungläubigen denn in jedem land wie zum
beispiel deutschland und den
niederlanden gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche muslimische
gemeinschaften mit ganz
unterschiedlichen gewaltpotenzial aber
in frankreich und belgien ist dieses
eben besonders schwerwiegend brad bitt
das ist nicht nur um terroranschläge
geht in städten wie paris und marseille
gibt das ganze stadtviertel in die sich
nur noch die polizei hinein traut und
manchmal noch nicht mal die was vor ein
paar jahrzehnten noch unvorstellbar war
ist heute bittere realität no go areas
und islamische parallel staaten mitten
in westeuropa zur neuen normalität
gehören dort radikalisierte gemeinden in
denen lehrer sich nicht mehr trauen in
staatlichen schulen frei zu sprechen und
frauen die sich nicht mehr so kleinen
können diese gerne würden wenn sie nur
mal ganz normal auf die straße gehen
möchten
daher musste präsident mal groß schon
lange das ist höchste zeit es die
reißleine zu ziehen und die enthauptung
samuel partie es war für ihn der letzte
tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
brachte makro sagte genug ist genug
[Musik]
makro geht hart gegen den islamischen
separatisten in muslimischen gemeinden
vor
reuters die ankündigung hatte der
gesamten muslimischen welt eine welle
des aktiv französischen rassist
ausgelöst die golfstaaten organisierten
boykotte die in französische produkte
und auch die präsidenten der türkei und
pakistans haben ihre bürger aufgefordert
keine französischen waren mehr zu kaufen
einige religiösen führer verglichen
makro mit hitler oder dem indischen
premierminister daran der amo die aber
solche vergleiche sind natürlich total
daneben und angesichts der schrecklichen
tat ein gipfel der geschmacklosigkeit
denn alles was man gesagt hat ist das an
den radikalen islam abschaffen will das
heißt er will gegen den islamischen
terrorismus und gegen seine ursachen
vorgehen nicht gegen die ganze religion
oder dagegen alle moslems niemand hat
gefordert alle moscheen zu schließen
oder alle muslime abzuschieben
nein es geht frankreich nur um den
schutz seiner eigenen freiheitlichen
werte welche auch sehr viele moslems
durchaus schätzt und die eigentliche
frage ist doch warum hat gerade
frankreich mehr probleme mit dem
islamischen radikalismus als andere
europäische länder wie zum beispiel
deutschland wieso ist ist das erste
europäische land in dem der clash of
cultures mit dem islam derart eskaliert
was genau schlägt konforme was will er
dagegen unternehmen und warum haben sich
so viele islamische führer gegen ihn
gestellt keine achse die ansonsten
werdet ihr bald erfahren aber zuvor last
ist wie immer ein wenig über geschichte
sprechen
er ist sohn namens ahmed in den
fünfziger und sechziger jahren erlebte
frankreich sein goldenes zeitalter und
was passiert wenn die wirtschaft eines
landes punkt arbeitskräfte knapp und die
unternehmen brauchen plötzlich viele
einwanderer um ihr wachstum zu
befriedigen woher kamen die
französischen einwanderer natürlich aus
den französischen kolonien in nordafrika
in ländern wie algerien und tunesien
warteten schon millionen von männern
daraufhin den fabriken von renault oder
testfall zu arbeiten schließlich hatten
sich schon in ihren heimatländern
französisch gelernt und ihre eltern
hatten ihn namen wie peru oder so pohl
gegeben sie identifizierten sich mit
frankreich und seinen werten und
heirateten gar französische frauen mit
anderen worten sie waren voll integriert
doch 1973 änderte sich das alles sehr
ähnlich er hat also produzierenden
länder der muslimischen welt beschlossen
ihr öl als politische waffe einzusetzen
1972 war das jahr der ölkrise eine krise
die frankreich besonders hart traf der
arbeitslosigkeit stieg und all jene
unternehmen die ein weiterer mit offenen
armen aufgenommen hatten begannen sie
die dazu entlassen
von einem tag auf den anderen braucht
dass frankreich keine einwanderer mehr
zur gleichen zeit machte die
französische regierung ein neues gesetz
auf den weg das sicherlich nur gut
gemeint war aber sehr gravierende
konsequenzen haben sollte
[Musik]
1978 verabschiedete frankreich das
gesetz zur familienzusammenführungen
dieses gesetz erlaubt es eingebürgerten
einwanderer familien aus ihren
herkunftsländern nach ziehen zu lassen
und es würde zu einem neuen gewaltigen
zustrom von einwanderern aus ländern wie
algerien und marokko
dabei handelt es sich aber nicht mehr um
männer im arbeitsfähigen alter sondern
einfach alle ihre familienangehörigen
natürlich erscheint diese politik auf
den ersten blick sehr human aber iran
sicherlich schon was das alles mit
islamischen radikalismus zu tun hat
trotzdem ist die dadurch ausgelöste
entwicklung doch etwas komplexer als
manche denken vor 1978 hatte alle
einwanderer die nach frankreich kamen
keine andere wahl als sich unter das
französische volk zu mischen wollten sie
nicht alleine sein mussten sie mit
einheimischen four schafften schließen
eine chaotische voraus finden und ein
französisches leben führen sie hatten
damit gewaltige anreize sich in die
französische gesellschaft zu integrieren
ab den 1970 er jahren konnten diese
einwanderer jedoch bereits frauen aus
ihrer heimat heiraten und diese blieben
die ist bei ihm tradition war zu hause
kontakte mit der französischen außenwelt
waren tabu ihrer welt war der heimische
herd das ehebett und die kinder
reagieren es gab auch immer weniger
bestehen und die kinder dieser
einwanderer die selbst pr oder auch
policen wurden nun plötzlich ahmed und
was angelangt
auch das mag auf den ersten blick nicht
als großes problem erscheinenden eltern
konnten ihre kinder ja nennen wie sie
wollen
doch zusammen mit diesem namen gaben die
traditionell erzogen wird jeder zweiten
generation auf den alten wertekompass
aus ihrer heimat mit und dieser
unterschied sich von dem der
französischen gesellschaft diametral
aus diesem grund fanden die ersten
debatten über das tragen des nikab in
der öffentlichkeit nicht in den 60er
jahren statt sondern erst ab 189 der
islamischen radikalismus in frankreich
hatte sich wie ein schwelbrand innerhalb
der abgeschotteten haushalte der
traditionsbewussten nachgezogenen mutter
entwickelt
richtig sichtbar wohl das problem aber
erst in den späten 1990 er jahren denn
ab dieser zeit beginnt frankreich auf
dem globalen markt an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu verlieren
seit dem jahr 2000 sind die nettoexporte
frankreichs weiter zurückgegangen
und wer sich deutschland zu einem
globalen industriellen machtzentrum
entwickelte du findest dich frankreich
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert im
wirtschaftlichen niedergang das ergebnis
paris der reichste stadt frankreichs hat
eine strukturelle arbeitslosigkeit vor
sage und schreibe acht prozent die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit erreichte gerade
19 prozent und ratet mal welcher gruppe
am stärksten von dieser arbeitslosigkeit
betroffen ist ganz genau
die nachkommen dieser nordafrikanischen
einwanderer der opulenten arbeit bei
renault und ihre kinder und enkelkinder
ahmed hassan sind arbeitslos das aber
ist noch lange nicht das ende dieses
traums
denn leider kommen in frankreich noch
ein paar weitere sehr ungünstige
faktoren zusammen
davon sind strenge vorschriften und
regelungen zum beispiel auf dem
wohnungsmarkt hast du noch in paris
gelebt hast weißt du genau dass es fast
unmöglich ist in der metropole an der
szene eine anständige wohnung zu finden
selbst hoch qualifizierte und gut
bezahlte arbeitskräfte die ich von
multinationalen prozent nach paris
gelockt werden können dann in alten
kleinen ungeheuren wohnungen landen laut
der website expert ist ankommt was man
gescheiter domain-name kostet die miete
einer 45 quadratmeter großen wohnung in
einem durchschnittlichen pariser
stadtviertel etwa 1200 euro pro monat
das ist ungefähr der gleiche preis in
münchen wohin liegt also der unterschied
nun der springende punkt ist dass
münchen eine arbeitslosenquote von 2
prozent hat wäre diese in paris bei sage
und schreibe acht prozent liegt und wenn
die experten ihren luxus gehältern sich
schon über die hohen preise beschweren
da stell dir vor was erst unsere
arbeitslosen freunde ahmed und hassan
dazu sagen willkommen in ihrem neuen
zuhause in so gut wie paris
nur einen steinwurf von der metrostation
stalingrad entfernt finden sie ihr
eigenes zuhause und das vollkommen
kostenlos wunderschöne parks mit den
besten drogenhändlern der stadt ein
bunter multikultureller städtische
umgebung für aktivitäten mit der ganzen
familie und hinzu kommen die besten
salafistischen moscheen die von unserem
fronten aus saudi arabien gesponsert
wurden zögern sie nicht denn ihr neues
trauriges leben in dieser auch für sie
erschwinglich nachbarschaft warteten auf
sie zu risiken und kosten fragen sie
bitte eine idee oder ihre schlepper vor
ort und was passiert in diesem
stadtviertel nun lasst uns mal einen
blick darauf werfen
die vorführungen des radikalismus ihr
leute sind der meinung dass der radikale
islam eine rückkehr ins mittelalter
darstellt eine ultrakonservative und
streng religiöse ideologie wie wir sie
eben vom mittelalterlichen christentum
erkennen ich wette dass das auch so etwa
deine vorstellung ist das ist aber
falsch die ideologie zu der sich die
meisten islamischen radikal in
frankreich bekennen ist der salafismus
des salafismus wurde in 18 jahrhundert
im heutigen saudi arabien erfunden
führte dort jedoch lange zeit eher ein
schatten dasein erst in den 1960 er
jahren wurde erst dominanten religiösen
bewegungen saudi arabien zu diesem
zeitpunkt war das land bereits zu jenem
monat geworden die es heute ist und die
herrscher familie erkannte dass sich das
salafismus gut dazu geeignet das eigene
volk unter kontrolle zu halten
sie musste dazu jedoch einen pakt mit
den salafistischen im angehen und diese
wollten hingegen so dass die saudis mit
den milliarden-einnahmen in die nacht
den bau von moscheen und islamischen
schulen in der ganzen welt finanzieren
dies erklärt warum gerade das rassismus
gegenüber anderen formen des islams so
stark an boden gewonnen erinnert ihr
euch zum beispiel auch an den ermordeten
lehrer partie nun
sein mörder stammte die gesagt aus
tschetschenien wo traditionell des trug
die islam praktiziert wurde in den
letzten jahrzehnten ist jedoch auch dort
des salafismus auf dem vormarsch und
etwas ähnliches geschieht ebenso in
frankreich im jahr 2004 gab es dort
bereits mehr als 5000 salafisten diese
salafisten konzentrierten sich natürlich
vor allem in ärmeren stadtvierteln dem
fristlosen religiös an den stadträndern
und sie sollten dort schon seit
jahrzehnten immer wieder für unruhe
ausschreitungen von immigranten in
frankreich dauern schon neun nächte new
york times ganz genau 2005 mit
frankreich drei wochen lang unter
anhaltenden randalen bei denen zwei
zivilisten getötet worden und mehr als
8000 autos in brand gesteckt wurden
spätestens da holte frankreich klar das
ist ein gewaltiges problem hatte und sie
wollten schon damals eine lösung finden
aber was meinst du welche das war
[Musik]
der französische rad des muslimischen
kunden eine theologischen rad um dem
radikalen diskurs entgegenzuwirken
europas lahm info ja um den vormarsch
des radikalen islam zu stoppen
frankreich ein regierungsorgan das mit
der muslimischen gemeinschaft
kommunizieren sollte die idee war eine
demokratie kompatible version des islam
zu fördern
obwohl einige kritiker sagen würden dass
frankreich nach dessen versuchte eine
eigene version des islam sollte werfen
und es ward ihr euch sicher ob dieser
rat irgendwie zur lösung beigetragen hat
nun urteilt selbst 2005 gab es in
frankreich etwa 5000 salafisten
im jahr 2010 waren es schon mehr als
12.000 heute sprechen wir sogar schon
von 30 bis 50 tausend aller festen also
wenn das ein exponentielles wachstum ist
ganz zu schweigen von all den
terroranschlägen mit den radikalen
moslems das land überzogen haben wie
aber fraglich ist könnte dann eine
funktionierende lösung aussehen
die wahrheit ist was bis heute niemand
weiß wie die radikalisierung einer so
großen zahl von norwegen überhaupt für
mich mitnehmen kann der
terrorismusbekämpfung ist eines der
wissenschaftlich und politisch
umstrittensten themen die es überhaupt
gibt es kursiert alle möglichen
lösungsansätzen spieler verschiedene
experten in saudi arabien hat man and
radikalisierung zentren geschaffen die
methoden zur rehabilitierung von
drogenabhängigen nach haben terroristen
machen dort dinge wie kunsttherapie
gruppendynamik und wahrscheinlich auch
regeln angeblich zumindest der
saudischen regierung zufolge soll ihr
damit aber ein großer erfolg so sein
aber würdest du dass jene regierung
abkaufen welche den salafismus erst in
aller welt verbreitet hat die realität
sieht leider so aus dass anderen in den
letzten jahren ja als 50 terroranschläge
durch menschen begangen wurden die
angeblich schon erfolgreich ein
radikalisierter waren forscher an
universitäten in spanien und kalifornien
haben sogar gehirnscans vor terroristen
durchgeführt um zu verstehen mit welcher
art von botschaften man einen
potenziellen terroristen and
radikalisieren kann
und während alle welt darüber streitet
wie das mit der radikalisierung und
radikalisierung eigentlich funktioniert
steigt die zahl radikaler moslems mit
nie dagewesener geschwindigkeit was also
schlägt in solch einer durchaus
ausweglos erscheinende situation
präsident rackow vor
[Musik]
der kreuzzug gegen den islamischen
separatisten was man an diesem punkt mit
gewissheit sagen kann ist dass eines der
hauptinstrumente der islam extremisten
radikale moscheen sind und die meisten
dieser moscheen werden mit geld bezahlt
das aus dem ausland kommt doch leider
lassen sich die spuren dieser
finanzströme nicht so einfach er google
wie ein erstklassiges rezept für leckere
shougang probiere es ruhig auch ruhig
mal beides für kuka und die finanzströme
aber du wirst im netz kaum einen
konkreten nachweis darüber finden wer
genau was bezahlt hat wieso nur im
gegensatz zu unternehmen müssen
religionsgemeinschaften ihre finanzen
nirgendwo offenlegen und darüber hinaus
sind religiöse organisation wie
entschied muss von allen steuern befreit
kein steuerprüfer wird also je einen
blick in ihre bücher werfen können ins
wo kommt noch ein weiterer faktor
salafismus ist keine griechische region
im gegensatz zum katholizismus gibt ist
kein salafistische papst oder so was
ähnliches wenn wir außerdem davon
sprechen dass saudi arabien den bau
einer moschee finanziert hat dann meinen
wir damit nicht die saudische regierung
denn in den meisten fällen handelt es
sich um private gruppen sind mal kurz
darüber nach es reicht wenn eine gruppe
saudischer millionäre einigen
freiwilligen in frankreich das geld für
den bau einer moschee überweist und im
gegenzug mit dem wohlwollen der
regierung war in ihren geschäften
rechnen kann
und schwupps schon ist es so gut wie
unmöglich festzustellen wer genau die
radikalen seubert macros plan ist es
daher ein nationales register aller
islamischen gotteshäuser aufzustellen
dabei sollen sowohl alle geldquellen
haargenau als auch die genaue art der
ideologie jeder einzelne moschee
ergründet und registriert werden
so soll es möglich sein radikal
vereinigungen leichter zu identifizieren
und zu zerschlagen denn das problem ist
ja dass sich diese häufig wieder einer
gemäßigten und freundlichen fassade
verstecken so wurde bereits das ngo
kollektiv gegen islamophobie in
frankreich verboten
in dem sich radikale moslems unter dem
deckmantel einer
menschenrechtsorganisation verschworen
haben darüber hinaus will makro auch den
hausunterricht verbieten und auf diese
weise sicherstellen dass alle kinder in
frankreich die gleiche vom staat
geprüfte bildung erhalten und genau
diese ausschaltung des einflusses von
ideologen aus dem ausland hat vielen
islamischen führern und dem türkischen
präsidenten die zornesröte ins gesicht
getrieben
[Musik]
europas muslime wurden behandelt wie
juden vor dem zweiten weltkrieg euronews
aber erdogan reichte diese absurde und
geschmacklose vergleiche nicht er
verhöhnte auch präsident makro
persönlich wegen dessen kampf gegen den
islamischen radikalismus als
geisteskrank wieso aber schießt erdogan
so scharf gegen die europäer welche
jedoch nur ausdrücklich den radikalismus
bekämpfen wollen nicht den islam hat
sich und wieso hält er gleichzeitig
brach seinen mund wenn das regime in
china
die muslimischen uiguren brutal
unterdrückt und eine million von ihnen
und erziehungs lagern festhält um ihnen
ihren glauben auszutragen was sind
deiner meinung nach andere motive sich
so sehr um das wohlergehen der
europäischen moslems zu sorgen wenn
ihnen gleichzeitig das schicksal der
menschen den ehemaligen ost turkestan
dem heutigen system jam vollkommen kalt
lässt scheint das auch mal in die
kommentare
die eine erklärung dafür ein feld wie so
erdogan hier nach derart krassen bitten
maßstäben handelt und nein wir sprechen
hier nicht von einem passiven wegschauen
sondern von aktiver beihilfe zu brutalen
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegen muslime
ja gar an den ethnischen mit dem türken
verwandten uiguren es erdogan zb in die
türkei geflohene uiguren eiskalt wieder
zurück nach china abschieben obwohl ihm
klar sein dürfte welches schicksal sie
dort erwartet geht es ihm am ende gar
nicht um die muslime selbst sondern eher
darum seinen eigenen einfluss in der
islamischen welt so billig wie möglich
zu vergrößern
denn es dürfte ihm klar sein dass ihnen
ähnlich hat der angriffe gegen china
nicht so ungestraft durchgehen würden
wie im falle frankreichs
die europäer müssen ihre milliarden ja
auch so nach uckerath überweisen wenn
sie nicht wieder unschöne bilder einer
flüchtlingswelle ertragen wollen
und so springt halt ob juristisch auf
jenes kostenlose tritt als auf das bei
islamischen führern gerade absolut in
ist der kauf begriff islamophobie hör
dir mal an was in ran kam der präsident
pakistans neulich vorsichtig
imran khan fordert die muslimische
länder auf der tendenz der islamophobie
in den europäischen ländern kollektiv
entgegenzutreten first post insbesondere
in der rede des pakistanischen
präsidenten werden die
mohammed-karikaturen sogar als hassrede
bezeichnet denn diesen mann zufolge
schließt die allgemeine rede- und
meinungsfreiheit keine lasten und ein
gewisser weise ist das natürlich
verständlich dass also denkt pakistan
gibt es keine trennung von staat und
religion ist dort seit vielen jahren
nicht mehr was meinungsfreiheit
überhaupt bedeutet ganz youtube zum
beispiel wurde in pakistan für drei
jahre verboten
sobald ein video erschienen war das
angeblich die gefühle von muslimen
verletzte und natürlich sind in pakistan
auch alle websites mit
erwachsenenunterhaltung verboten und das
kann ich mir schon gar nicht vorstellen
und wenn ihr denkt so was würde uns im
westen nicht so schnell drohen dann
schnappt euch jetzt mal gut dann an
genau dieser stelle erliegen viele
menschen dem simplen realistischen
gedanken dies alles sei ganz einfach ein
krieg zwischen freiheitlichen westlichen
werten auf der an- und respektive
islamischen werten auf der anderen seite
ein klassischer crash zweier kulturen
aber weit gefehlt denn die fronten
dieses freiheitskampfes verlaufen quer
durch alle kulturen hindurch bedürfnis
für keinen moment vergessen dass viele
westliche führer in ihren ansichten mehr
oder weniger mit den aussagen des
pakistanischen präsidenten übereinstimmt
es hat sich eine sehr mächtige und sehr
bunte koalition gebildet die sich auf
die rede und meinungsfreiheit sowie die
andere von unseren vorfahren hat er
kämpfte menschen und bürgerrechte
eingeschossen hat und viele vertreter
dieser freiheiten hatten sich in der
mitte der westlichen kultur gemeinschaft
auf 8 zum beispiel darauf was papst
franziskus nur wenige tage nach den
blutigen anschlägen auf charlie hebdo
aus sondern man kann nicht provozieren
man kann die überzeugungen anderer
menschen nicht beleidigen man kann die
menschen nicht verspotten
man kann den glauben nicht verspotten
wenn doktor gaspar ihm ein großer freund
ein böses wort gegen meine mutter sagt
steht ihm einen schlag bevor also wenn
das keine unverfrorene anmaßung gegen
unsere freiheitliche und aufgeklärte
wertegemeinschaft ist welche sich einen
jahrhundertelangen kann
auch gegen die zu einer totalitären
unterdrückung organisation entartete
katholische kirche durchsetzen musste
denn an dieser stelle halte ich es für
wichtig eines klarzustellen redefreiheit
schließt blasphemie satire und
beleidigungen eine religion ausdrücklich
ein künstler diesmal lesen oder haben
ganze karrieren auf das knie aufgebaut
und das ist gut so
wir alle haben ja die ganze filme wie
das leben des kleinen gesehen welche
ohne religiöse satire absolute witzlos
werden aber all das wird durch die
meinungsfreiheit ja perfekt abgedeckt
niemand aber auch wirklich niemand
sollte angst davor haben dass er
benachteiligt oder gar ermordet wird
wenn eine religion ideologie oder eine
politische idee kritisieren oder
persifliert deswegen müssen wir das
recht auf reale meinungsfreiheit mit
zähnen und klauen verteidigen
deswegen ist emanuel makros kampf so
wichtig und deswegen ist es auch richtig
dass sich ihm alle anderen führer die
von sich behaupten für die freiheit
einzutreten anschließen leider ist dies
die machen und sehen musste keine
selbstverständlichkeit auch viele
westliche politiker wollte es sich nicht
mit der dunklen seite der macht
verderben oder neigen gar selbst dazu
mit totalitären ideen zu synthetisieren
wir haben in diesem video papst vom
fiskus als ein beispiel angeführt damit
ihr euch die spannweite dieser
gefährlichen denkmuster vor augen führt
den vögeln videos haben wir euch mit
anderen beim spielen erzählt zum
beispiel von der deutschen bafin im
falle wirecard oder von der whu im falle
chinas welche weiteren beispiele fallen
euch ein durchdrehen oder durch was seht
ihr das recht auf freie
meinungsäusserung besonders bedroht
schreibt sie immer alles in die
kommentare dazu aber zurück was
frankreich natürlich darf man nicht den
fehler machen markus plan für perfekt zu
halten in walle erdogan und jemand an
zum toben bringt ganz im gegenteil er
wird viele rechte kritik die
schwachpunkte
allein dass die regierung den namen des
gesetzes vom gesetz gegen separatismus
in gesetz zur stärkung republikanischer
prinzipien umbenannte führt den hohen
grad der kontroverse vor augen das wort
islamismus kommt übrigens mit absicht
nicht im gesetzestext vor genauso wie in
diesem video und die kritik kommt von
beiden politischen seiten linke und
islamverbände sehen in dem vorhaben
islamfeindlichkeit
eine stigmatisierung der muslime
rechtsextremen geht der vorstoß
natürlich dagegen nicht weit genug
doch mag rom hat absolute härte
gegenüber den radikalen islam
versprochen er machte klar dass
frankreich nicht um das eingeständnis
herumkommen dass der ausufernde radikale
islam umland die werte der republik
untergrabe gut ist die gewalt
banalisieren denn es geht herzstück der
coronation die 1905 eingeführte
französische la cité de nur bedanken der
trennung von religion und staat und
natürlich darum die werte der republik
vor dem radikalen islam zu verteidigen
darüber aber wie die nazis muss man
heute aussieht muss die französische
gesellschaft einen neuen konsens finden
denn auch diese trennlinie verläuft die
gesagt nicht strikt zwischen moslems und
nichtmoslems deshalb wollen wir jetzt
eure meinung zu diesen kontroversen
thema wissen
haltet ihr es für richtig dass das
französische stars diese maßnahmen zur
regulierung eine religion ergreift
glaubt ihr das mal groß plan das problem
des islamischen staates ist es wirklich
lösen wird oder wurde der point of no
return in frankreich bereits
überschritten schreibt uns bitte alles
was ich dass du ein feld in die
kommentare
denn die insel sind wir auf diese schon
hoch gerade ist gestand ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen ist und
vielleicht etwas gebracht hat was ja
geht uns mit einem like und unterstützt
uns in de es mit euren freunden teilt
und vergesst bitte nicht dass wir jede
woche neue videos hochladen abonniert
also unseren kanal und klickt auf das
gelingen sowohl um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden
machs gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]